Salam alaikum. Uh my name is Jakpa
Isnan. Uh I'm 22 years old. Uh and I'm
uh working in West Bandong and I am
Muslim.
>> What do you work as?
>> What
>> what is your work?
>> Uh operator.
>> Operator.
>> Yeah. Uh I have a question actually. Uh
my question is from my non-Muslim
friends. uh he has uh uh the question uh
about uh existing
god
uh why in Muslim the god have not imag
uh same like uh in uh video uh in dr
uh uh same like uh in reference in yaj
naimi
hernatima or in Sanskrit uh painting
picture idol uh but uh he asked uh it is
logical you worship him but you don't
know he looks like okay thank you
>> uh doctor he's asking the brother's name
is Jqua he's an operator he's saying
that we believe he have seen a lot of
your videos and all that uh he believes
in the that god exist and you have
preached that there is no image of God
so how do we worship God when we don't
even have his image age and something
like that.
>> Is there a question?
>> Yes, doctor.
>> Okay. Brothers asked that how how can we
worship God without an image.
Number one, if you make an image of God,
you're belitting him.
Belitting him
because Veda says God has no image.
Bible says God has no image. Quran says
God has no image. So how can you and
that remind me that if you read in the
Quran Musa Alisam he asked Allah that I
want to see you. So Allah tells him I
will show myself to the mountain. You
look at what happens to the mountain and
Musa Alisam falls down. When he sees the
N of Allah on the mountain, he didn't
see Allah and he fell down. So that is
the greatness of Allah subhanana wa
tala. You ask me the question, how can
you worship Allah without having its
image? Without having the image, you
don't have to have the image of
everything that you want to think about.
It's not necessary that you should have
a image of everything that you want to
think about. It's not a must. For
example, you don't have to have an image
to believe.
Suppose someone has told you America is
a very good country, very beautiful
country. You want to go there. So, do
you have to see the picture of America
to go there?
>> Uh, no.
>> Not may may see, may not see. Everything
is not a must.
Seeing everything is a mush and
especially we in Islam and the other
religions also they don't believe
because Allah subhanana wa tala is so
supreme in this life you cannot see him
next life you see him that is if you go
to Jenna if you go to Jenna so it's not
necessary that if we have to worship
what do we do we follow the guidelines
of Allah subhanaa tala when we worship
We stand
in the cayam. We do ru we do sujud. When
you're doing sujud,
you are prostrating to Allah subhana wa
t'ala and saying he's the greatest
because our body is under control. Our
mind is not directly under control. So
when you do sujud, you are putting the
highest part of the body, the forehead
on the lowest part of the ground. And
subhan Allah, glory be to Allah the most
highest. So this is a form of worship.
When we when we worship Allah subhanana
wa ta'ala, we are repeating the words of
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala.
Alhamdulillah,
glory be to Allah, the lord of the
worlds. You tell me one thing
all the images that you know of God that
you see other religious people do it in
mistake.
any religion
whatever photographs you have seen of
God of other religion what is so unique
in that tell me
>> what is
>> I don't know
>> like you and me one nose one mouth two
eyes what is so great the heroes and
hero and in the movies they look better
than them right or wrong
>> right or wrong
>> uh wrong
>> yes
>> don't the heroes in the movie look
better than the gods photograph
>> yes
>> right or wrong
You got understand
>> the hero you see in the movies
>> don't they look better than the
photographs of the god?
>> Yes.
>> What if the photograph that they see
they worship? What makes them god? If I
see that photograph I will not feel like
worshiing because he's looking like me.
Correct.
>> Yes. Correct.
>> Why should I worship someone who has
same qualities like me? One nose, one
mouth, two eyes like me. What is so
unique? Allah says
there's nothing like him. The moment you
can compare God to anything in this
world, he's not God. That is by
definition. In Islam, the definition of
Allah is there nothing like him. And
you're saying, give me an image. The
moment you give an image of God, that is
not God. Do you understand?
>> Yes, I can understand.
>> The moment you give an image of God in
Islam, that cannot be God because God is
far superior. So we worship him because
of his ability. He's our creator. He's
our sustainer. We worship him because
seeing his signs. The sun is a sign.
Moon is a sign. Star is a sign.
>> Do you understand?
>> Understand?
>> The benefit he has given to us. The
Quran that we have when we read the
Quran, we have faith in him. It is not
by photograph. The photograph will take
me away from God. If that is God,
>> yes,
>> one God requiring the help of other God,
one God killing other God. God dies for
3 days. If God dies for 3 days, why
should he worship such a God? Right or
wrong?
>> You know, God died for three days.
>> Yeah. Right.
>> Which God photograph you like the best?
Tell me.
>> Which God?
Uh I think uh uh no uh correct.
>> Yes.
>> Therefore, God not having image is the
best to elevate God to a higher
standard. Hope that answers the
question.